haben heute in deutschland genau eine
eine mitteilung der
bundesinnenministerium vernommen es geht
um das thema regenbogenflagge eine
flagge die ich großartig finde weil ich
zum einen die farben wunderbar finde und
weil ich das ganze was hinter dieser
flagge auch steckt für sehr sehr
bewundernswert halte und eine große
leistung die frage die sich aber
aufdrängt ist jetzt und das ist das was
nancy faeser heute beschlossen hat
muss diese flagge auch vor öffentlichen
gebäuden hängen sollte sie vor
öffentlichen gebäuden hängen darf sie
vor öffentlichen gebäuden hängen und da
habe ich sagen in diesem staat nein es
gibt ein neutralitätsgebot des staates
und es gibt ein recht zu sagen wir
stellen vor öffentlichen gebäuden
hoheitliche flaggen auf also
beispielsweise schwarz rot gold statt zu
gold im übrigen eine flagge die für
freiheit steht die für offenheit steht
die für toleranz steht und die auch für
ein modernes deutschland steht unter dem
sich so wie ich der meinung alle
menschen hier im land versammeln können
ich gebe ihnen herr schäfer absolut
recht wir haben klare regeln in
deutschland welche flaggen sich vor
welchen gebäuden befinden dürfen und wir
haben die hoheitlichen flaggen wenn wir
ausländische gäste empfangen dann kommt
auch noch die flagge des fonds des
landes noch hinzu ja oder die flagge des
bundeslandes ja und natürlich auch der
bundesrepublik deutschland und der
europäischen union das ist das was für
unseren behörden hängt wenn wir jetzt
die regenbogenflagge auch noch aufhängen
dann stelle ich die frage wo soll das
denn ändern welchen flaggen wollen wir
den späteren noch hinhängen dann kommt
wieder eine bewegung und noch ein trend
und noch irgendein thema ja und dann
befinden wir uns auch wieder in einer
politischen debatte die irgendwo kein
ende findet ich möchte erinnern an die
situation die wir ich glaube es ist
ungefähr ein jahr her wo viele
unternehmen in der deutschen wirtschaft
sich dazu entschieden haben auch diese
flaggen vor ihrem betriebsgelände
aufzustellen das hat zu heftigsten
diskussionen geführt in der gesellschaft
man hat sich mal wieder in eine ecke
gedrängt gefühlt man hat sich mal wieder
einer meinung aufgedrückt gesehen und
das hat so und ruin geführt und in der
tat ich glaube wir sollten uns hier auf
das nötigste beschränken auf das was
wirklich auch die bundesrepublik
präsentiert und nicht die
regenbogenfahne wissen auch um gar nicht
missverstanden zu werden jeder kann
diese regenbogen flagge hissen wenn er
möchte ist doch ein wunderbares zeichen
kann sie aus einem fenster hängen kann
sie vor seinem garten aufstellen auf dem
balkon wie auch immer dagegen ist
überhaupt nichts zu sagen es ist eine
freie entscheidung seine tolle flagge
soll jeder machen die frage ist immer
nur neutralitätsgebot des staates ist
und da glaube ich ist es gut wenn man
sich da auf das beschränkt was wir
bisher haben vorzeichen aber sie sind
natürlich einer meinung doch klar er
will einmal allerdings fast ein anderer
bommersbach rein weil ich sonst würden
sie wieder zu schnell wenn sie nicht
genug zu wort kommen frau berichtete
etwas wenn wir zweifel will das ist ganz
großartig liebe vorschlägen im grunde
das ist meine ganz persönliche meinung
jetzt hätte ich bei speziellen bei ganz
besonderen veranstaltungen
beispielsweise ganz konkret csd breite
gerne christoph später in berlin kein
problem damit keine bauchschmerzen mit
ganz grundsätzlich sehe ich jetzt aber
sehr ähnlich dass wir schon eine
wunderbare flagge haben und die steht
für unsere demokratie alles was damit zu
tun nicht und wir sagen mit dieser frage
drücken mit der aus dass wir niemanden
ausgrenzen weder aufgrund seiner
religion auch aufgrund seines
geschlechts was immer das heißt sie
steht für toleranz steht für offenheit
steht für freiheit und somit auch für
frieden vor allem auch für ein
friedliches zusammenleben
die flagge steht für toleranz und
dementsprechend das ist ja deine tier
sie an impliziert sie schon
gesehen sieht also wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe dann geht es nicht darum
dass die flaggen gehisst werden müssen
sondern dass die gefühle fragen gehisst
werden dürfen ich verstehe überhaupt
nicht die debatte ehrlich gesagt ist mir
zum jahr 1960 dass man darüber
debattieren ob vor einem amtsgebäude in
regenbogenflagge gehisst werden darf
oder nicht ernst das diskutieren wir
hier in deutschland das sieht man in
österreich schon viel weiter und wie es
normal dass die hinterwäldler also in
österreich haben wir den amtsgebäuden
auch wenn der amtsträger oder die
amtsträgerin entscheidet sie möchten ein
zeichen setzen zu einer parade oder
einfach auf grund eines gewässers oder
einfach weise ein zeichen setzen möchte
dann tut sie das das jetzt überhaupt zu
debattieren also dass wir jetzt
überhaupt noch darüber reden müssen ob
das ob wir jetzt quasi in eine ecke
gedrängt werden oder ob deswegen die
deutsche fahne abgewertet wird oder
relativiert wird und so weiter ganz
offensichtlich ist diese politikerin der
meinung dass es wichtig ist dass man
auch als staat ein zeichen setzt und ich
finde das gut und richtig ich bin so
aber nicht homosexuell aber ich finde es
gut und wichtig dass das auch mal
gezeigt das als staat diese dieser
beißreflex dass man nicht wieder
verstehen wenn es irgendwie ein anlass
um im bundestag beschlossen wird es
müssen alle regenbogen fahnen gehisst
werden können darüber debattieren würden
wir wahrscheinlich auch zu weit gehen
aber ganz ehrlich da wurde gesagt sie
möchte dass es möglich sein kann was für
ängste haben sie bitte in sich dass sie
angst davor haben dass irgendjemand
einen
anschlag gegen ein zeichen indem wir
nach recht und gesetz leben indem wir
unser grundgesetz haben das ist das was
uns lenkt und leitet und finde damit ist
dem thema auch genüge getan aber sie
haben das ja glaube ich richtig gesagt
und das beantwortet ein bisschen ihre
frage
die frage ist ja wie geht es dann weiter
und das ist immer so ein punkt glaube
ich über den mann sprechen muss wir
haben es hier mit einem einem sehr
starken symbol für toleranz und freiheit
zu tun aber es könnten vielleicht auch
gesellschaftliche gruppen auf die idee
kommen da andere flaggen hissen zu
wollen und dann kommen wir auch sehr
schnell als gesellschaft immer in diese
frage ja wem erlauben wir jetzt
eigentlich noch was das ist ja genau die
debatte und deswegen es ist glaube ich
gut wenn ein staat ein neutralitätsgebot
habe es gab in berlin in den vergangenen
jahren als zum csd beispielsweise auch
schon vor behörden gehisst wurde
polizisten die sich weigerten das zu tun
so und dann wurde ihnen mit
disziplinarverfahren gedroht weil die
polizisten sich auf das
neutralitätsgebot des staates das ist
hier sehr gutes recht berufen haben die
sind ja auch im einsatz die müssen dann
ja auch dokumentieren und auch sagen ich
stehe jetzt für den neutralen staat so
da wird es ja sehr problematisch und
das glaube ich muss man sehr ernst
nehmen und deswegen hat der staat in
deutschland habe ich bisher gute
erfahrungen damit gemacht zu sagen wie
ich hab wir verhalten uns in gewisser
weise sehr sehr neutral aber schaut kann
sich auch weiterentwickeln würde und ich
glaube wenn wir im jahr 2002 anführt
sind die deutsche fahne schon toleranz
impliziert nein wenn ich mir anschaue
was in deutschland alles alltag ist das
nicht von toleranz geprägt dies wie ich
glaube wir haben vor kurzem gestern oder
vorgestern eine riesen aktionen gegen
rechtsextremismus in deutschland gehabt
dann muss ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen nein
ich glaube nicht dass es als implizit
ist und vor allem dürfen wir den fehler
nicht machen dass wir von unserer andere
spieler zu glauben dass wenn sie jetzt
die fahne anschauen und deswegen und so
weiter mit implizieren das ist schön
dass ich diese gefühle haben wenn sie
die fahne an schon großartig aber ich
glaube so ganz viele menschen fühlen
sich diskriminiert aufgrund von lauter
mini das auf haben schauen sie ich hatte
selber sichtbare migrant ich habe selber
rassismus erfahrungen gemacht das heißt
nicht dass ich mir jetzt wünsche dass
irgendwelche antirassismus flaggen
gehisst werden aber ich kann gut
nachvollziehen dass menschen die
vielleicht nicht das privilegiertem haus
kommen die vielleicht nicht von klein
auf gelernt haben dass sie zur gruppe
der stärkeren gehören sich auch einmal
wünschten dass der staat ein zeichen
setzt und mein gott was ist das problem
angehen helge endlich willst
so schnell passiert aber bis morgen
abend war